[Musique]
bonjour à tous et le seul rendez-vous
parlementaire 1 qui subsiste en cette
période de crise sanitaire les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
cet après midi elles sont toutes
consacrées cette semaine encore au
coronavirus avec des questions sur le
volet sanitaire bien sûr mais aussi sur
le volet économique mais aussi des
questions sur l'école les examens ou
encore le monde de l'agriculture
tous les groupes politiques sont
représentées encore cet après midi dans
des conditions qui respectent les
conditions sanitaires
ils ne sont que 18 sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle et 10 d'entre eux vont
pouvoir questionner le gouvernement
pendant environ un petit peu moins d'une
heure ça commence d'ailleurs dans dix
minutes
mais pour l'instant je suis avec claude
malhuret bonjour vous êtes président du
groupe les indépendants je précise aussi
votre métier puisque vous êtes médecin
vous avez été infectiologues vous avez
aussi travaillé pour un groupe de
maisons de retraite médicalisées et
d'ailleurs et de l'actualité elle porte
notamment sur les ehpad est ce que pour
vous aujourd'hui
les seniors sont en danger dans les
ehpad en france ils ne sont pas plus en
danger que
que cela ce mets bien entendu qu'ils
sont en danger comme tout le monde je
dirais ils sont en danger peut-être plus
que le monde pour trois raisons la
première c'est que j'en étais pas les
personnes sont âgées moyenne d'âge 85
ans c'est que elles sont souvent avec
beaucoup de pathologies associées et
c'est troisièmement qu'elles sont
regroupés par conséquent bien entendu ça
les met dans une situation particulière
ce qui fait que ça fait peser des
responsabilités et un travail
supplémentaire pour les soignants manque
de protection beaucoup ont dit qu'il
manquait de masques etc rennes
aujourd'hui et bien scénario catastrophe
ce sont leurs mots et je pense que ils
doivent est évidemment prioritaire ans
qu au cinéma parce que d'ailleurs
certains d'entre eux sont des soins des
soignants même s'ils ont des
accompagnants mais il ya beaucoup de
soignants et donc ils doivent tous être
protégé les avantages si je peux dire
c'est que dans les maisons de retraite
on est habitué aux épidémies hivernales
et notamment la grippe c'est la terreur
de la grippe hivernale c'est l'intérieur
des maisons de retraite
donc ce le cas en un virus c'est un
virus différents mails avantage c'est
que les mesures de protection sont les
mêmes que pour la grippe et par
conséquent ce personnel c'est parait
assez urgent c'est à ces épidémies
est ce que vous craignez des chiffres
très importants de surmortalité dans les
ehpad on a appris hier qu'il y avait
donc 240 morts supplémentaires dans les
hôpitaux au coronavirus en france mais
on nous a bien dit eh bien ça ne prend
pas du tout où les chiffres en compte et
notamment la surmortalité dans les ehpad
oui et il y aura une surmortalité mais
elle sera difficile à apprécier
parce que dans les ehpad comme je le
disais à l'instant l'hiver on meurt
beaucoup de la grippe
pas seulement des pathologies à d'autres
pathologies mais beaucoup de la grippe
et comme les symptômes sont les mêmes et
qu'on ne va pas testé tout le monde on
ne pourra jamais savoir qui est mort de
la grippe ou qu'ils aient monde du
coronavirus donc la surmortalité
elle va exister mais tous les hivers il
y a une sur mortalité due à la grippe
comme certains étaient il ya une
surmortalité due à la canicule
vous parlez des tests claude malhuret
justement le ministre dit qu'il faut
désormais démultiplier ces tests qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ce changement de
stratégie français est ce que nous
étions mal préparés à cette crise quand
on constate et bien le manque de
réactifs ou encore découvrions qui sont
nécessaires à ces tests qui sont
rapportés alors je dirais deux choses
premièrement tous les pays du monde à
l'exception peut-être de la corée du sud
était mal préparé cette épidémie elle a
surpris tout le monde donc en france
comme ailleurs il faut s'y adapter
la deuxième réflexion c'est que ce
changement de stratégie il est dû à un
changement dans la progression de
l'épidémie
à partir du moment où les tests seront
utilisés surtout à partir du moment où
on va céder ses c'est le confinement
pour pouvoir tester tous ceux qui seront
qui auront des symptômes suspects à ce
moment là donc ce changement de
stratégie
il est un changement de période dans
l'économie dans l'épidémie et il
arrivera d'ailleurs probablement un peu
plus tard puisqu'il correspond à la fin
du confinement est ce que vous vous
joignez aux demandes de commission d'
enquête sur cette crise à rendre entendu
encore gérard larcher ce matin du côté
des nerfs il ya cette demande du côté du
ps aussi il va falloir tirer les
enseignements de cette crise alors bien
sûr partout comme je le disais il ya un
instant en dehors de la corée du sud il
semble bien qu aucun pays du monde
n'était préparé et partout où il va
falloir savoir préparer la prochaine
parce qu'il y aura dans un an dans deux
ans dans dix ans une prochaine crise de
cette nature donc il va faire là la
préparer et tirer les leçons
mais je voudrais pas non plus il sera
temps de le faire lorsque l'épidémie
sera fini je voudrais pas non plus que
tirer les sens ça veut dire règlement de
comptes
oui moi je préférerais qu'on appelle ça
une mission d'information il ya deux
sortes de possibilités mission
d'information ou commission à
l'assemblée déjà avec les pouvoirs d'une
commission douala les conditions dans
lequel ça fait toujours voilà ça fait
enquête et ça fait toujours un peu
règlement de quoi donc moi je pense que
oui bien sûr il faudra le faire plus tôt
sous forme à mon avis d'une mission
d'information et d'une commission
denquête mais nous verrons plus tard
une dernière question vous allez poser
une question tout à l'heure sur les
assurances ans dans la crise du
coronavirus quel est le problème
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise qui
s'aperçoivent que les conditions les
clauses de leur assurance ne prévoit pas
ou plutôt exclut les crises sanitaires
massive et bien entendu ça va leur poser
un problème évident et par conséquent ma
question c'est est-ce que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui prévoit des
modalités assurantielle par exemple
qu'on pourrait comparer à celle des
catastrophes naturelles qui fasse que
les chefs d'entreprise ne se retrouvent
pas
change aucun sans aucun recours face à
une baisse d'activité qui risque d'être
catastrophique pour beaucoup d'entre eux
merci beaucoup claude malhuret d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
vous allez donc tout à l'heure interrogé
1 le gouvernement sur ce sujet et je
vais maintenant accueillir à bien le
sénateur l air de seine-saint-denis
philippe dallier bonjour philippe
dallier
vous êtes également vice président du
sénat tout d'abord votre regard sur ces
25 ordonnance qui ont été adoptées ce
matin en conseil des ministres certaines
vise à assouplir le droit du travail
notamment avec cette durée du travail
qui est peut être poussée jusqu'à 60
heures dans les entreprises est
essentielle est-ce que vous jugez que
c'est normal ou est-ce que vous jugez
que le droit du travail est malmené même
si c'est temporaire
on va d'abord rappelé effectivement que
c'est temporaire parce que j'ai entendu
beaucoup s'est exprimé sur le fait qu'on
était en train de détricoter
complètement le code du travail
non nous sommes dans une situation très
particulière extrêmement grave avec un
impact effectivement sur les entreprises
est forcément sur l'emploi donc il faut
essayer de s'y adapter pour une période
qui restera j'espère relativement courte
peut-être quelques mois mais il faut
bien comprendre que si nous ne faisons
rien beaucoup d'entreprises y ont au
tapis et les gascons considère ce sont
plutôt des bonnes mesures pour vous
c'est nécessaire s'applique à nous les
avons le sénat a adopté à la quasi
unanimité le projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui a été adopté en fin de
semaine dernière voilà il faut
effectivement prendre des décisions peut
pas attendre que le temps passe et
constater les dégâts après tout vous
allez d'ailleurs tout à leur poser une
question sur les dispositifs de soutien
aux entreprises qui sont prévues le
gouvernement annonce notamment un fonds
de 1 milliard d'euros prévus pour aider
les tpe les micro entreprises les
indépendants ce n'est pas suffisant pour
vous écouter il ya des mesures
intéressantes on les a votés mais il ya
effectivement peut-être des trous dans
la raquette et c'est ce qu'il faut
essayer de corriger notamment les
mesures sur le chômage partiel
effectivement on a beaucoup de tpe
commerçants artisans qui reste ouvert
parce que leur secteur d'activité fait
partie des secteurs essentiels et qui
pourront s'en vont voir leur chiffre
d'affaires baisser
donc on voudrait effectivement qu'ils
puissent bénéficier de sa disposition
et puis il ya surtout c'est peut-être le
plus important le paquet de 300
milliards de garanties de prêts
accordées par l'état effectivement pour
ces entreprises il faut que le secteur
bancaire soit en mesure et en capacité
c'est la question que je vais poser de
distribuer très largement et très vite
ces prêts parce que la survie de
beaucoup d'entreprises va indépendant
philippe dallier ce matin martin hirsch
a lancé un appel très alarmant pour
l'ap-hp 1 qui concerne toute
l'ile-de-france il s'inquiète du manque
de respirateurs du manque de médicaments
il appelle à la réquisition des
soignants et à leur reconnaissance
peut-être même sous forme de primes est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui alors
que l'on approche et bien du pic 2010
mouvement il fait des besoins il ya des
besoins médicaments matériels tout ça
c'est un autre aspect on les applaudit
le soir à 20 heures c'est bien mais on
peut aussi leur marquer notre
reconnaissance d'une autre manière
et ça fera partie de la question que je
vais poser parce que pour l'instant on
n'a qu'une prime de 1000 euros mais qui
ne va concerner que les salariés et
probablement les salariés les grandes
entreprises
et c'est tout oui l'amour qu'elle
fragilise la prime donc je pense
politiquement faut aller beaucoup plus
loin et permettre dans la fonction
publique hospitalière
effectivement de récompenser ceux qui
sont au boulot et qui aujourd'hui font
un travail formidable donc
financièrement et avec une prime
effectivement financièrement d'une
manière ou d'une autre alors vous étiez
aussi parmi ceux qui avaient critiqué un
finalement le maintien du premier tour
philippe dallier
on apprend maintenant qu'on a un peu
plus être quasiment une dizaine de jours
de ce premier tour qu'il ya eu des
assesseurs qui pensent avoir été
contaminée lors du premier tour des
présidents de bureau des maires aussi
qui veulent faire annuler ce premier
tour et puis on a toutes les difficultés
on sait que ce premier tour il va être
annulée si le deuxième tour peut pas
avoir lieu en juin
est ce que pour vous il fallait donc
l'organiser écoutez on va pas y revenir
vous m'interrogez le samedi soir quand
manifestement on avait changé
dans la crise avait changé d'ampleur
puisqu'on nous annonce et le confinement
il aurait peut-être fallu prendre la
mesure ça n'a pas été le cas c'est ainsi
faire mon cette page là ça n'est pas le
moment de d'en parler il ya des choses
beaucoup plus graves en ce moment une
toute dernière question est ce que pour
vous il faut continuer à maintenir ces
questions d'actualité dans ce format
actuel on pense que bientôt on va
pouvoir passer à des visioconférences
que vous avez et bien des informations
sur ce sujet philippe dallier il semble
effectivement que ce soit la dernière
séance dans l'hémicycle mais il faut
maintenir les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
c'est inscrit dans la constitution ça
fait partie du contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement par les mondes par les
parlementaires et tout ça ne doit pas
s'arrêter même en cas de crise grave
il faut que cela continue mais ça peut
se faire à distance ça se fera à 10 ans
oui eh bien merci beaucoup philippe
dallier d'avoir répondu à mes questions
alors que eh bien on va bientôt pouvoir
rejoindre l'hémicycle puisque la séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
va pouvoir commencer d'un instant à
l'autre
je vous le rappelle est bien que la
preuve les procédures sanitaires sont
parfaitement suivi pour que puisse se
tenir cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
voilà on vient de voir gérard larcher le
président du sénat qui s'installe il va
pouvoir présider cette séance de
questions il va y avoir une dizaine de
questions qui sont posées par les
sénateurs ils sont seulement 18
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle parmi les
personnes qui vont répondre noter qu'il
va y avoir notamment le premier ministre
edouard philippe
mais aussi et bien la secrétaire d'état
anya ce panier une hache et olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé va lui
aussi être invités à répondre à des
questions ainsi que jean michel blanquer
voilà et bien la cloche vient de sonner
tout de suite les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
[Musique]
pas reçu d'observation il y en a t'il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé sur le premier ministre
madame et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions de contrôle au
gouvernement si nous mesurons la gravité
de la situation qui justifie les mesures
exceptionnelles adoptées ces derniers
jours et que nous soutenons le sénat a
le devoir d'accomplir de manière adaptée
sa mission constitutionnelle de contrôle
de l'action du gouvernement
nous devons assurer la continuité de la
vie démocratique de notre pays
une autre séance de questions se tiendra
la semaine prochaine
je voudrais rappeler à nos compatriotes
qui le regardent actuellement
l'importance du respect des mesures
notamment de confinement telles qu'elles
sont demandées par le gouvernement qui
sont fixées par la loi d'urgence
sanitaire pour les français qui nous
regarde je précise que nous siégeons en
effectif restreint adapté aux
contraintes sanitaires et en accord avec
les présidents des groupes politiques
que je voudrais remercier et et saluent
avant de laisser la parole aux auteurs
des questions je voudrais vous faire
part des suites données à nos débats de
la semaine dernière sur le projet de loi
d'urgence et sur le projet de loi de
finances rectificatif je vous ai adressé
deux lettres monsieur le premier
ministre pour rappeler les engagements
pris par le gouvernement devant notre
assemblée
je souhaite on a dit qu'il est honneur à
nos collègues
la première rappelle que l'adoption sans
modification du projet de loi de
finances rectificatif est à la fois
consciences et exigence
il reviendra au gouvernement de
travailler à l'élaboration d'une mesure
simpliste mais efficace notamment pour
soutenir la rémunération des salariés et
des indépendants qui travaillent dans
des conditions délicates et assure la
continuité de notre vie économique et
c'est pour nous aussi essentiel il
faudra informer le parlement de manière
précise et régulière sur le déploiement
des mesures de soutien à l'activité
économique ainsi que sur l'impact de la
crise sur l'hôpital public et les
collectivités locales second courrier
souligne l'engagement pris par le
gouvernement dimanche on séance publique
monsieur le ministre s'était vous même
je suis ministre en charge des relations
avec le parlement d'informer
mensuellement les commissions
permanentes du sénat des mesures prises
en application de la loi d'urgence
destinées à faire face à l'épidémie de
comics 19 d'information porte sur trois
points les actes pris par l'exécutif et
six représentants locaux dans le cadre
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
les dispositions envisagées par le
gouvernement dans les ordonnances et
leur décret d'application note que nous
avons reçus dès hier soir
je note avec satisfaction de matignon
une fiche sur l'e25 ordonnance qui ont
été présentés ce matin
ce premier ministre en conseil des
ministres les mesures troisième fois
prises pour assurer la continuité du
fonctionnement des assemblées
délibérantes locales les modalités
d'organisation du second tour des
élections municipales le sénat entend
accomplir la plénitude des missions que
lui confie la constitution dans le
respect des contraintes que nous impose
la situation sanitaire dans un juste
équilibre entre ces contraintes et
l'exigence démocratique
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous
monsieur le premier ministre pour
établir entre nous et une collaboration
confiante et le gouvernement sait
pouvoir compter sur le sénat souhaite
également qu'une attention toute
particulière sur le premier ministre
soit portée à deux compatriotes d outre
mer et aux français et
adli hors de france nous recevons
nombreux messages et je crois que c'est
pour nous essentiel nous qui les
représentent ont aussi et nous devons
porter ces messages que nous recevons et
je vous garantis que nous ferons notre
la priorité sanitaire notre séance de
questions et comme à l'accoutumée
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
et sur notre site internet
la parole est à notre collègue rené paul
savary pour le groupe
les républicains vous avez deux minutes
sans merci monsieur le président j'ai eu
l'honneur de poser la première question
dans un contexte très particulier elle
s'adresse bien sûr à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre je
voudrais tout d'abord rendre hommage à
toutes celles et ceux qui bien sûr sont
sur le front en première ligne mais
aussi ceux qui sont en arrière ligne et
qui rendent un service à nos concitoyens
et un hommage tout particulier au nom de
mon groupe pour aller mes confrères les
médecins décédé au champ d'honneur
mais l'incompréhension des français
devient de plus en plus manifestes sur
l'ensemble des territoires et je voulais
vous faire remonter cette information
des titres locaux sont claires dans la
presse locale la crise des masques
c'était le titre d'hier le titre
aujourd'hui c'est l'état de d'urgence
dans les maisons de retraite
alors je voudrais vous poser quelques
questions monsieur premier ministre qui
s'adresse également au ministre de la
santé bien sûr concertons état sanitaire
grand 1 qu'en est il des masques arriver
non pas les masques commandés mais les
masques à grives et grande qu'en est il
de ces traitements qui s'ils ont le but
de diminuer la charge virale peut-être
faut-il mieux les prescrire en début de
l'épidémie plutôt qu'en fin d'épidémie
en 3 qu'elle est
les mesures qui vont être prises en ciel
qui concerne l'articulation entre le
public et le privé nous avons des lits
en clinique qui sont vides il ya plus de
consultations de spécialistes et les
lits sont vides alors que les secteurs
publics et surchargé et quatrièmement
quelles sont les mesures d'anticipation
de vous comprendre
pour la sortie du du confinement
notamment en ce qui concerne les tests
merci pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre des solidarités et de la sorte
et monsieur olivier vers en juin 2010
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur savary je vous remercie pour
votre question qui me permet de faire un
bilan à date des moyens qui sont mis à
disposition de celles et ceux qui
soignent des vies dans les hôpitaux et
et en médecine de ville
sur l'ensemble du territoire national et
en particulier dans les régions sous
tension tout d'abord vous dire si je
j'entends cette rumeur sur la
participation des hôpitaux privés
elle est inexact l'ensemble des hôpitaux
publics et privés se sont vus intimer la
consignes très strictes d'arrêter toute
activité programmée depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines de libérer toutes les
places en soins intensifs et en
réanimation
ce savary j'ai appelé moi même les
cliniques par exemple de la région grand
est
j'ai appelé moi même les directeurs des
cliniques de la région grand est de mon
cabinet la scène et s'en est assuré
c'en est assurée les lits qui sont
disponibles dans les établissements
privés à ce stade son délit qu'on trouve
également dans le secteur public pour
pouvoir accueillir des malades non
qu'ovide les cliniques participent
totalement à l'offre de soins elles sont
totalement mobilisés et je les en
remercie d'ailleurs et c'est important
de le renvoyer de signal tout le monde
est sur le pont
s'agissant des questions la question des
masques j'ai annoncé que 70 millions de
masques avaient été stockés depuis le
début de l'épidémie fin février que 20
millions de masques supplémentaires et
aient déstocké à destination des
établissements de santé et des ehpad
cette semaine notamment dans les régions
où le virus circule le plus jeune est
pas caché la situation
la consommation de masques est encore
plus massive du fait des
caractéristiques du virus dans les
territoires dans les hôpitaux le virus
circule et les deux fondamentale
d'apporter en priorité la protection aux
personnes qui travaillent dans les
services de réanimation auprès des
malades les plus les plus graves
c'est
indispensable j'ai autorisé comme le
haut conseil de santé publique le
demandait la prescription collégiale
sous la responsabilité du médecin qui le
décident de traitement par hydroxy
chloroquine aux malades les plus graves
hospitalisés en l'absence de
recommandations et en parallèle de cela
je l' ai déjà dit il ya plusieurs
centaines de patients qui sont dans les
différents hôpitaux français en train de
participer à des protocoles cliniques à
différents stades de la maladie
il ya même un protocole d'étude qui va
être lancé dès le début de la maladie
pour tester différentes molécules dont
celle que à laquelle nous faisait
allusion de manière à ce que la
recherche puisse nous permettre le plus
rapidement possible si nous avions le
moindre argument scientifique et médical
qui permettent de concilier sécurité et
efficacité de le rendre disponible sans
délai aux français croyez moi la
mobilisation est totale du ministère des
soignants de l'ensemble des agences de
l'assurance maladie des casa sud
tout le monde est sur le pont monsieur
le sénateur croyait le public et privé
tout le monde est sur le pont
chaque heure de chaque jour et de chaque
nuit sur l'épaule favori
la situation est compliquée monsieur le
ministre et je comprends que vous
écoutiez bien sûr les remontées de vos
administrations c'est tout à fait
légitime et écouter aussi les remontées
des élus parce que la grogne est en
train de la grogne est en train de
monter et paint est en période de guerre
peut-on prendre des décisions qui ne
soit pas scientifiquement correcte mais
qui permettrait parfois à la population
d'être soignés dans des bonnes
conditions
on a besoin de masse qu'on aura besoin
de tests on a besoin de traitement donc
faut peut-être anticipé notamment pour
sortir du confinement derrière c'est ce
à quoi je pense je vous remercie
merci la parole et à notre collègue
vincent capo-canellas ce pour le groupe
de l'union centriste vous avez la parole
mme sur le testeur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs mes chers collègues ma
question concerne l'agriculture
hier les marchés ont été interdits dans
des conditions qui peuvent d'ailleurs
appelé débat pour compenser le manque à
gagner le ministre de l'économie a
enjoint à la grande distribution et on
peut le rejoindre sur ce point
à acheter des produits français mais
dans le même temps nous savons que du
fait de la fermeture des frontières
l'agriculture va manquer de saisonniers
au cours des mois à venir
environ 200 mille d'entre eux feront
défaut naudy la fnsea et c'est
d'ailleurs un enjeu considérable
auxquels nous devons faire face dans ce
contexte de mise en culture a lancé hier
un vibrant appel aux français pour
lorsqu'il sur ses activités qui visent à
y travailler dans les champs cette
déclaration a d'abord suscité
l'incompréhension
alors que des mesures de confinement
viennent d'être renforcées comment des
centaines de milliers de personnes
pourrait-elle rejoindre les campagnes
pour prêter main forte à nos
agriculteurs
et pourtant l'appel semble avoir été
entendu puisque plus de quarante mille
personnes se seraient déjà porté
volontaire et le gouvernement ensuite
hier soir tard annoncé par communiqué la
création d'une plateforme dédiée alors
hors de question se pose comment ce
dispositif
va-t-il fonctionner en particulier dans
quelles conditions sanitaires
par ailleurs si la mobilisation est
insuffisante comment notre agriculture
pourra-t-elle continuer de répondre à la
demande n'y at il pas un risque de
pénurie
ce sont des questions légitimes que se
posent nos agriculteurs et les français
pour vous répondre
la ministre du travail est là me muriel
prix que vous avez la parole si le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
capo-canellas ce oui c'est un sujet très
important la santé notre priorité à tous
garantir une alimentation de qualité
dans les semaines et mois qui viennent
est essentiel c'est le printemps le
printemps ça veut dire que c'est
l'époque des premières récoltes et c'est
l'époque des semis pour l'automne c'est
pour ça que depuis quelques jours nous
avons travaillé le ministre de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation d'une
liste de l'économie des finances et moi
même avec les professionnels du secteur
pour faire face ensemble la situation
que vous avez décrite il faut pour les
semaines qui viennent 200000 saisonniers
dans 70 milles venez avant comme
travailleurs détachés pour cela nous
fait donc trois choses premièrement
d'ici la fin de la semaine
mon ministère produira avec les
professionnels du secteur
un guide des bonnes pratiques de santé
et de sécurité pour que les travailleurs
saisonniers et travailleurs de
l'agriculture soit sûr de travailler en
toute sécurité pour leur santé
deuxièmement nous avons lancé une
plate-forme qui est commune à pôle
emploi et les finisseurs et qui va
permettre de collecter toutes les offres
et les demandes avec un point journalier
ensemble département par département
pour permettre que tous les emprunts
sont pourvus troisièmement nous avons
décidé et ça a été annoncé ce matin dans
le cadre des ordonnances suite à la loi
d'urgence que nous autorise aurions le
cumul entre le chômage partiel et
l'activité agricole saisonnières pour
les semaines qui viennent
en clair quelqu'un dont l'actif qui ne
travaillent plus parce qu'une entreprise
a fermé ou une activité affirmé pourra
venir en renfort de façon volontaire
bien sûr dans les champs pour aider les
agriculteurs en cumulant le bénéfice du
chômage partiel et la rémunération et le
contrat de travail dans le secteur de
l'agriculture
nous faisons de même avec le fonds de
solidarité pour les indépendants ou un
indépendant qui ne peut plus mener son
activité je pense aux restaurateurs aux
bars qui sont fermés et bien pourront
aussi venir en renfort en cumulant
l'indemnité de 1500 euros du fonds de
solidarité et le contrat dans
l'agriculture je crois qu'on est tous
sur le pont pour la santé on doit tous
être sur le pont pour l'alimentation je
me réjouis du travail qu'on mène avec
tous les professionnels sur le sujet
madame lise merci ces éléments 3,3
question reste quand même en suspens la
première c'est d'un point de vue
sanitaire comment le comité scientifique
ira-t-il ces mesures d une question
économiquement s'il n'y a pas assez de
monde s'il ya passé de main d'oeuvre la
question la pénurie pour à ressurgir et
enfin à plus long terme
sans doute est il besoin de mesures plus
spécifiques au secteur agricole de
mesures de soutien
sachant que un certain deux secteurs
sont particulièrement touchés et que les
mesures qui ont été prises ici sont des
mesures jusque là un peu général du pôle
économique je pense au chômage partiel
aux heures supplémentaires qui
toucheront pas forcément beaucoup le
secteur agricole merci la parole est à
notre collègue le président thani
mohamed
soilihi pour le groupe de la république
en marge avait la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
messieurs le ministre des solidarités de
la santé depuis lundi minuit
les vols entre l'hexagone et d'outre-mer
sont interdits sauf dérogation
exceptionnelle des autres maires ne sont
pas épargnés par cette pandémie
plus de 330 cas confirmés de communes à
virus soit à ce jour diagnostic et qui
s'ajoute parfois comme c'est le cas à
mayotte et à la réunion à ceux liés à
l'épidémie de la dengue d'une
exceptionnelle en pleurs ce nombre est
certainement sous-estimé d'apparence
moins touchées la situation sanitaire
compliqué de ces territoires liés à leur
insularité leur isolement et leur
éloignement mais surtout à la faible
capacité d'accueil des malades fait
unanimement craindre une explosion du
nombre de contaminations mon département
qui a connu son premier cas le 14 mars
en compte aujourd'hui 35
vous connaissez la faiblesse du système
de santé à mayotte
malgré le travail considérable des
professionnels soignants que je tiens
ici à remercier chaleureusement
l'hôpital déjà saturé ne compte que 16
lits de réanimation et seuls 28 médecins
libéraux exerce dans ce territoire pour
une population officielle de 257 milles
habitants mais qui s'élève probablement
au double en raison de l'immigration
clandestine une grande partie de la
population vit dans des conditions de
précarité et de promiscuité propice à
l'expansion de cette épidémie sur place
les gestes barrières et de confinement
ne sont pas bien respecté
souvent par impossibilité comment faire
autrement lorsque l'on vit à plusieurs
dans une habitation traditionnelle sans
accès aux sanitaires
mais pour ceux qui peuvent respecter ses
règles et qui agissent par insouciance
je vous le redis ne prenez pas ce virus
à la légère
ne croyez pas que le climat ralentir à
sa progression et restez chez vous pour
protéger vos familles hier par
audio-conférence le préfet et les élus
de mayotte tous très mobilisés avons
fait le point
monsieur le ministre hormis les mesures
sur les transports aériens
pourriez-vous nous dire les dispositions
prises par le gouvernement pour aider
les territoires ultramarins
particulièrement vulnérables à faire
face à cette pandémie on voudrait voir
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur permettez moi de
m'associer à vos propos monsieur le
sénateur sur le coup de chapeau pour le
dire trivialement que vous lancez
professionnels de santé notamment à ceux
du centre hospitalier de mamoudzou et à
tous les centres associés car la
situation difficile à laquelle il doit
faire face depuis longtemps j'allais
dire indépendamment de cette épidémie de
deux coronavirus et tels que elle elle
suscite pour beaucoup d'entre nous pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens une grande
inquiétude
vous avez souligné les efforts consentis
depuis quelques années pour essayer de
réhausser le niveau 2 de préparation le
niveau de soin susceptibles d'être
apportées notamment à mayotte
je sais que votre question dépasser très
largement le simple cadre de mayotte
avec la création de cette agence de
santé qui doit permettre une meilleure
organisation des soins avec les moyens
supplémentaires donnés à l'hôpital de
mamoudzou et chacun ici en tête les
moyens importants qui sont mises en
oeuvre notamment en guadeloupe pour
construire un nouveau chu plus résilient
mais qui n'est pas encore terminée et
pour faire face à des situations de
santé qui vont être complexe la vérité
monsieur le sénateur c'est que cette
épidémie est à prendre au sérieux et
qu'elle est à prendre au sérieux peut
être encore plus dans les territoires
insulaires compte tenu des
caractéristiques que vous avez vous même
évoqué c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons pris des décisions qui sont
des décisions très rude de limitation
voire de très grandes limitations des
vols commerciaux à destination des
autres maires de façon à limiter au
maximum les flux et les échanges de
population entre des territoires qui
sont j'allais dire par nature plus
fragile sur le plan de l'organisation
sanitaire que la métropole
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
en plus de ces restrictions sur
l'utilisation des vols commerciaux nous
avons imposé à tous ceux qui partaient
vers les territoires ultramarins 14ème
stricte à leur arrivée néanmoins vous le
savez je le sais un certain nombre de
cas sont à déplorer en guadeloupe à la
martinique à mayotte et sur d'autres
territoires ultramarins notre objectif
c'est d'abord d'affirmer clairement la
solidarité de la nation à l'égard de
tous ces territoires territoires
ultramarins bien entendu tous ces
territoires
c'est aussi de veiller à freiner
peut-être plus encore compte tenu des
limites de l'offre sanitaire existantes
freiner encore plus fort que sur le
territoire métropolitain à la
circulation et la propagation du virus
ce qui explique que les préfets seront
peut-être sans doute amené à prendre des
mesures strictes et notamment des
mesures de couvre feu par des mesures de
confinement plus sévère encore que celle
qui prévalent sur le territoire
métropolitain
j'ai indiqué lors de mes dernières
expressions orales que sur tout ou
partie du territoire si les
circonstances l'exigeaient nous serions
amenés à prendre des mesures plus dures
dans l'immédiat j'ai demandé à
l'ensemble des préfets de me faire
remonter leurs propositions
compte tenu de l'analyse fine de chacun
des territoires car évidemment la
situation est différente en guyane et à
la réunion en nouvelle-calédonie et à
mayotte afin de pouvoir prendre les
mesures y compris plus dures que celles
qui prévalent actuellement sur le
territoire métropolitain
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons
freiner la circulation du virus en
sachant que bien entendu s'il fallait
projeter un certain nombre de moyens
supplémentaires à destination des
outre-mer nous le ferions dans la limite
de nos capacités
c'est comme cela que nous pourrons aider
les populations françaises à faire face
à ce qui est je le dis sans ambages et
sans fard un défi considérable qui
s'annonçait nous merci monsieur sénat
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole à notre collègue joël labbé pour
le groupe du rassemblement
pratique et social européen vous avez la
parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues tout d'abord au nom de
mon groupe rdse je voudrais affirmer
notre solidarité envers l'ensemble des
personnes qui sont mobilisées dans cette
lutte en particulier les personnels
soignants
ma question le 23 mars la décision est
tombée comme un coup de massue sur les
territoires le gouvernement a interdit
l'ensemble des marchés sauf autorisation
d préfet après avis des mères pourtant
sur le terrain de nombreux marchés
avaient déjà mise en place de bonnes
pratiques allant bien au delà de celles
des grandes surfaces dans lesquelles les
clients peuvent circuler manipuler
librement les produits pourquoi créer du
gaspillage à nîmes alimentaire et une
rupture d'égalité de traitement entre
des grandes surfaces et les marchés où
se trouvent des acteurs locaux porteurs
de résilience
car par cette décision ce sont notamment
des petits producteurs en vente directe
mais aussi des acteurs de la pêche
artisanale et des ostréiculteurs qui
voient leur survie économique menacée
alors que l'alimentation est un secteur
stratégique n'est-il pas nécessaire de
soutenir et sécuriser les marchés et
l'ensemble des initiatives de vente
directe la réponse sur ce sujet votre
réponse monsieur le premier ministre à
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas permis de
véritablement clarifier la situation et
ces deux mesures continuent de faire
fortement débat sur nos territoires
oui il faut faire confiance au maire
mais se sentiront-ils eux mêmes en
confiance pour demander des dérogations
alors que les préfets ont des
interprétations diverses de l'arrêter et
que certains ont déjà refusé des
demandes aussi pouvez vous madame la
ministre
avoir une parole bien clair pour
encourager les maires et les préfets à
maintenir des marchés et les pratiques
de vente directe dans le respect des
règles sanitaires pour vous répondre la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je vous réponds à cette
question car je sais qu'elle suscite
beaucoup d'interrogations beaucoup
d'appréhension même
de la part des agriculteurs qui ont
besoin de ces marchés pour écouler leur
production de la part de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui ont besoin de ces
marchés pour pouvoir s'approvisionner
s'approvisionner pardon en produits
frais et la part des élus qui se
trouvent parfois des préfets aussi
qu'ils se trouvent confrontés à des
décisions délicates à prendre je
voudrais donc essayé essayé d'être le
plus clair possible pour répondre à
votre question le principe
le principe est celui de l'interdiction
des marchés c'est le principe général
car il nous semble que il vaut mieux
être prudent sur le plan sanitaire et
posé un principe d'interdiction mais à
ce principe d'interdiction
il est possible d'apporter des
dérogations ces dérogations doivent être
autorisées par les préfets sur demande
et à vis des maires qui sont les mieux
placés mieux que quiconque pour
apprécier si dentelle commune le marché
est à la fois nécessaire et susceptibles
d'être organisés en respectant les
conditions sanitaires les conditions de
sécurité sanitaire qui sont exigés par
le gouvernement
et quand je dis les maires sont les
mieux placés que sont les mieux placés
pour apporter cette appréciation dans
leur commune ou dans tel ou tel quartier
de leur commune
j'insiste sur ce point vous savez
monsieur le sénateur que j'ai été maire
je sais très bien que dans une ville
dans une grande ville il y à des marchés
qui parce que la disposition des lieux
et elle rend impossible le respect dans
de bonnes conditions des conditions
sanitaires mais qui dans d'autres
endroits sont des tout petits marchés
locaux qui servent à approvisionner en
produits frais la population de tel ou
tel quartier et qui peuvent être
parfaitement organisés en respectant les
conditions
il appartiendra donc au maire de faire
cette demande de dire oui là je le sais
nous pouvons d'ailleurs veillé à ce que
le marché soit bien organisé et le
préfet
les préfets pourront prendre des
dérogations allons allant dans ce sens
vous avez évoqué monsieur le sénateur la
question de l'interprétation par les
préfets de cette règle générale et de
cette possibilité de dérogation il nous
faut évidemment bien l'expliquer c'est
ce que j'ai fait c'est ce que le
ministre de l'intérieur va continuer à
faire car les préfets et comment leur en
faire le reproche monsieur le sénateur
sont évidemment d'abord motivée par les
impératifs de préservation de la santé
et donc par la limitation au maximum des
risques on ne peut pas leur en faire le
reproche monsieur le sénateur car s'il
n'avait pas cette préoccupation première
sans aucun doute certains viendrait leur
faire le reproche inverse et il serait
dangereux compliqué pour eux par pardon
de déroger au principe mais nous allons
expliquer le sens de cette règle est mon
objectif je vous le dis très simplement
c'est que dans les communes rurales où
le marché est indispensable et peut être
organisée dans de bonnes conditions
dans les quartiers des grandes villes où
le marché peut être organisée dans de
bonnes conditions ils puissent se tenir
pour une raison simple c'est que nos
agriculteurs ont besoin d'écouler leur
production et nos concitoyens ont besoin
de s'approvisionner en produits frais ça
n'est pas un luxe
ça n'est pas un accessoire c'est
indispensable
il faut simplement le faire dans des
conditions de civisme et de respect des
conditions sanitaires suffisantes et
encore une fois je le dis et j'ai
plaisir d'une certaine façon à le dire
au sénat ce sont les maires qui sont les
mieux armés les mieux placés pour faire
cette proposition et les consignes que
nous passerons au préfet seront
évidemment des consignes aux écoutes et
des consignes de bon sens il leur
appartiendra à prendre les décisions
mais ils sauront ils seront le faire
dans de bonnes conditions et peut-être
monsieur le préfet c'est vrai qu'entre
le moment de l' annonce et le moment de
la mise en oeuvre
il y a eu des questionnements posés ça
peut arriver
nous allons les régler le plus
rapidement possible merci monsieur le
premier ministre la parole est
maintenant à monsieur l'abbé pardonnez
moi vous avez quelques secondes excusez
moi merci monsieur le président
l'urgence aujourd'hui est à la suivre à
la souveraineté alimentaire des
territoires pas à la seule concentration
des pouvoirs des grandes surfaces
parce que malgré tout il y à quelque
part distorsions de concurrence pour le
temps d'après qui ne seront plus jamais
comme les temps d'avant notre
agriculture paysanne aux producteurs
locaux
nos territoires ruraux sont porteurs de
beaucoup d'avenir alors préservons les
dès maintenant je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente
eliane assassi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique
vous avez la parole madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
l'heure est grave l'épidémie de
coronavirus s'étend sur toute la planète
et notre pays est particulièrement
frappé des mesures exceptionnelles sont
prises mais elles ne sont pas
suffisantes nos hôpitaux nos ehpad appel
à l'aide
ils ont besoin de masse qu'ils ont
besoin de tests ils ont besoin de
réanimateurs et bientôt de médicaments
l'incapacité de la sixième puissance
économique mondiale à fournir ce qui
pourrait paraître une évidence et
dramatique
cette incapacité est révélatrice du
ravage du libéralisme système que vous
portiez onu avec d'autres mais ça
c'était avant
l'état doit maintenant reprendre la main
un état citoyens au service du peuple
deux voies d'actions immédiates si vous
permettez monsieur le premier ministre
il faut ré ouvrir et nationalités
nationalisées en urgence
lusine luxe faire seuls fabricants en
europe de bouteilles à oxygène fermés il
y a quinze mois par son propriétaire
britannique
les 134 ex salariés ont maintenu en
l'état le matériel annoncé la
nationalisation et la réouverture
ensuite décidé aujourd'hui la
réquisition d'une usine de textile pour
la fabrication massive des masques
contrairement à d'autres elles sont
aujourd'hui indispensables à la gestion
de l'urgence sanitaire
alors oui c'est vrai et emmanuel macron
a raison quand il déclare qu un modèle
de développement dévoile ses failles au
grand jour nationaliser n'est plus un
gros mot
monsieur le maire et vous même l'évoquer
le medef lui même abjure le gouvernement
d'y recourir
les sociétés construite sur la quête du
profit la concurrence la primauté des
intérêts privés va scheer la crise
sanitaire en est le terrible révélateur
oui il faut redonner à l'état
la maîtrise du destin de notre pays mais
concrètement mais contrairement au medef
nous ne voulons
pas de nationalisation temporaire pour
sauver les actionnaires je pense qu'il
faut effectivement définitivement libéré
les services publics de la loi du marché
donc messieurs près ministre allez vous
engager des mesures immédiates et à long
terme
ces ruptures dont le pays a cruellement
besoin aujourd'hui pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente
il y a plusieurs temporalités dans votre
question il y à la question d'urgence et
j'ai évidemment il irait essayer de
répondre aux questions que vous posez et
puis il y en a près le monde que nous
souhaitons une fois que la crise urgente
que nous connaissons sera traversée mais
je l'espère traversée dans les
meilleures conditions
je ne vous surprendrai pas madame la
présidente en disant que le monde
d'après peut-être nous ne voyons pas
exactement de la même façon
ça veut pas dire d'ailleurs que nous
sommes par définition en désaccord sur
tout mais ça veut dire que l'idée selon
laquelle le j'ose à peine parler de
d'appropriation collective des moyens de
production
non mais je sais que vous ça ne vous
dérange pas mais pas exactement ma façon
de voir le monde d'après ne ne recueille
pas tous mes suffrages si j'ose dire
mais nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre et après tout ce sera un débat
sain et un débat nécessaire sans doute
s'agissant des mesures d'urgence
un mot d'abord pour dire que le plan
qu'a présenté le gouvernement est un
plan qui se monte vous l'avez compris à
45 milliards de mesures d'urgence
immédiate
auxquels s'ajoutent 300 milliards de
garanties apportées par l'état sur les
prêts consentis par les banques il
s'agit pas de défendre les banques il
s'agit de faire en sorte que les
entreprises puissent obtenir un
financement qui leur permet de continuer
à vivre 300 milliards de garanties
données par l'êta c'est loin d'être
négligeable et l'ampleur du plan
l'ampleur du plan correspond d'ailleurs
si on le rapporte à la population à la
norme de ce qui est fait par exemple par
nos voisins allemands ou par d'autres
pays comparables
cela veut dire que nous mettons beaucoup
de forces dans la capacité à surmonter
la crise mais madame la présidente
sur ce point est sur le point que je
vais évoquer nous pouvons sans doute
nous retrouver lorsque nous aurons
réussi à passer la crise car nous la
passeront il faudra relancer la machine
il faudra faire repartir le corps
économique qui aura été frappé par je
dit pas s'il faut parler d'un arrêt
cardiaque en tout cas par une
interruption de la circulation sanguine
et cet effort de redémarrage sera
probablement considérable il ne devrait
d'ailleurs pas être seulement nationale
même s'il aurait une dimension nationale
évidente faudra qu'ils soient
coordonnées au niveau européen au niveau
mondial sans doute bref il y aura un
champ considérable d'action économique
collective et publique à mettre en
oeuvre
vous avez évoqué l'instrument des
nationalisations l'état est d'ores et
déjà actionnaire d'un certain nombre de
grands groupes qui lui paraissent
stratégiques ou dans lequel le
l'histoire a fait qu'il ait des
participations les deux des ans
n'étant pas incompatibles il n'est
évidemment pas actionnaire il n'a pas
vocation à être actionnaire de toutes
les entreprises françaises ou de toutes
les entreprises qui exercent leur
activité notamment en france sur la
question des entreprises dans lequel
l'état est déjà actionnaire déjà
actionnaires l'etat sera appelé à
prendre ses responsabilités il les
prendra
s'il est déjà actionnaire d'une
entreprise et s'il fallait prendre des
mesures pour veiller à l'outil
industriel ou à l'outil économique dont
la france est en partie ou complètement
propriétaire évidemment l'état prendra
ses responsabilités s'il fallait au delà
des entreprises dans lesquelles l'état
est déjà actionnaire intervenir soit par
des prêts particuliers soit par des
prises de participation dans des
entreprises que nous jugeons stratégique
et qui seraient mises en difficulté par
l'interruption de l'activité ou même
madame la présidente menacés dans leur
existence ou dans la répartition de leur
capital par des interventions qui nous
paraît très posé des problèmes
sur étrangères par exemple qui nous
paraissaient pose des problèmes alors
nous avons dit le ministre l'économie
les finances l'a dit je les dis en tant
que chef du gouvernement
nous prendrions là aussi nos
responsabilités et nous essaierions et
nous avons bon espoir de pouvoir y
parvenir de faire en sorte que ces
entreprises puissent passer la crise et
repartir de l'avant dès lors que la
crise sera passée
nous n'excluons donc aucun mouvement
mais vous comprenez bien compte tenu de
l'ampleur des sujets qu'annoncé par
principe des interventions de l'état
ce serait se condamner à l'impossibilité
de les réaliser tout
nous allons donc être extrêmement
mobilisés je peux vous dire que au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
on regarde ça avec un oeil est
extrêmement attentif pour voir où et
quand il conviendra d'intervenir en
fonction de la capacité des dites
entreprises à passer cette période
délicate et du caractère stratégique ou
non qu'elles peuvent revêtir pour le
tissu productif national ou pour la
souveraineté française
je réponds en termes généraux j'en ai
conscience je réponds dans des termes
qui ne vous satisfont pas parce que non
nous n'allons pas nationaliser
l'ensemble de l'économie française
même l'ensemble des entreprises
industrielles je vais un peu loin mais
parfois en écoutant votre enthousiasme
je me dis que l'on pourrait aller très
loin si on vous suivez mais n'allant mai
mais en tout cas nous sommes extrêmement
mobilisés pour faire en sorte de pouvoir
réagir le moment venu sur les
entreprises qui présentent évidemment un
intérêt un atout majeur pour la
souveraineté française
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole de notre collègue
rachid tu es mal pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain avait la
parole dans chers collègues
confinés chez eux
touché par la maladie par le deuil mais
aussi pour tous nos compatriotes qui
assure en séjour des fonctions
essentielles et vitales pour notre pays
en termes de santé et d'entretien
d'alimentation de sécurité
d'enseignement de production encore de
continuité du service public
face à cette crise sanitaire sans
précédent le gouvernement le parlement
et les collectivités ont dû adopter des
mesures sanitaires strictes mais vitale
alors que la période de confinement a
initialement annoncée sera prolongée
nous pouvons constater deux premières
conséquences économiques et sociales
comme celle d'une tension naissante sur
certains prix déjà visibles dans
l'hexagone et les outre mer aussi nous
incombe est présent de préparer dès à
présent aux conséquences de la crise sur
le pouvoir d'achat des français
nous devons anticiper cette situation et
prend des décisions immédiatement dès
lors face à cette inflation de crise
nous demandons au gouvernement en
application de l'article 2 de la loi
d'urgence adoptée ce week-end de bloquer
par décret les prix des produits de
première cité d'alimentation et
d'hygiène
nous demandons également au gouvernement
de mettre en place un dispositif pour
maintenir le poids d'achat des
agriculteurs et des producteurs
aussi madame la ministre pouvez vous
nous dire quand sera pris sur des quais
de craie pardon de blocage temporaire
des prix pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame agnès pannier une
hache et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
il avait la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur était mal
permettez-moi d'abord de saluer tous
ceux qui contribuent dans les commerces
petits et grands dans les usines sur les
routes et dans les entrepôts à nourrir
67 millions de francs smic parce qu'il
mérite aussi un coup de chapeau
aujourd'hui dans les conditions de
travail qu'ils doivent tenir le
gouvernement suit bien entendu
l'évolution du prix des denrées
alimentaires et notamment des produits
frais une première analyse ventre que
sur ces produits frais moins de 10 % ont
connu une augmentation d'un peu plus de
10% sur la semaine du 16
au 22 mars et je me fonde sur les
chiffres de rungis
bien sûr nous sommes très vigilants nous
sommes très vigilants dans un contexte
où les coûts de production augmentent et
le coût pour amener cette nourriture au
plus près des français je pense
notamment aux coûts logistiques comme
vous le savez les conditions de travail
sont plus difficiles plus difficile
aussi de transporter de la marchandise
de faire de remplir à plein son camion
il y a bien sûr des mesures qui existent
d'abord les accords de modération des
marges sur les fruits et légumes freine
que prévoit le code rural et de la pêche
maritime
cela concerne 16 accords que nous
pouvons activé et qui ont été activés
récemment sur les fraises ronde et
gariguette car il faut être précis et
les asperges et puis nous avons
effectivement la possibilité si nous
assistons à une flambée anormal de
prendre des mesures de fixation des prix
en application du code du commerce
et c'est pour cela que j'ai demandé à la
dgccrf de suivre de très près
l'augmentation de ses prix mais je veux
dire aussi ici que l'enjeu que nous
avons c'est de nourrir les français ce
que nous faisons en faisant un point
tous les jours avec l'ensemble de la
filière agroalimentaire et en nous
assurant d'enlever tous les grains de
sable qui bloque l'acheminement des
marchandises et cela va ça n'a été
indiquée du manque de personnes de bras
dans l'est dans les fermes jusque dans
la logistique les entrepôts et au final
dans la distribution il faut lutter et
être très solidaire aussi dans la façon
dont nous consommons nous les français
je veux le souligner merci monsieur
rachid tu es mal madame la ministre
j'entends votre réponse et nous avons
les uns les autres je crois le souci à
la fois de nourrir les 67 millions et de
permettre à notre filière agricole de
pouvoir y cultura lecture de pouvoir
effectivement travailler
j'entends ce que vous me dites mais ce
que je vous dis c'est qu'il faut
anticiper
il ya aujourd'hui déjà sur les marchés
sur dans l'est dans les magasins des
augmentations et je le dis il faut
anticiper et cette logique que vous avez
adopté que nous avons des le
collectivement sur les prix j'espère
qu'elle pourra être activée on l'a fait
sur le gel hydro
alcoolique qui a été nécessaire et vous
le voyez bien aujourd'hui sur un centre
de produits il ya une augmentation en
aussi en outre-mer parce que nous avons
des retours et il faut je crois qu'il
faut activer cette cause là dont déjà
disponibles qui existent je crois qu'il
faut maintenant le mettre en place
merci mon cher collègue la parole et au
président claude malhuret
pour le groupe des indépendants vous
avez la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre dans une
crise sanitaire comme dans toute
catastrophe l'action publique doit
d'abord parer au plus urgent protéger
les vies humaines quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est la ligne retenu par le
gouvernement celle soutenue par le
parlement et surtout celle attendue par
les français et je voudrais pour
commencer me joindre à l'hommage qui a
été rendu par les orateurs qui m'ont
précédé à tous les personnels soignants
de notre pays
mais après les mesures drastiques pour
limiter l'expansion du virus il faut
agir avec autant de force pour que
l'économie ne s'effondre pas nous avons
contribué en adoptant dimanche dernier
les deux projets de loi que vous nous
aviez soumis le gouvernement dispose
désormais d'importants moyens pour
tendre à nos entreprises de nécessaire
filet de sécurité
mais l'état ne peut pas tout alors que
tout indique un ralentissement globalisé
de l'économie la mobilisation du secteur
privé sera également indispensable
aucune des forces vives du pays ne doit
manquer à l'appel
bon nombre de nos entreprises accusent
le coup et s'apprête à ouvrir des lignes
de crédit garanti par l'état mais afin
de remettre les entreprises sur les
rails de l'activité l'action des
professionnels de l'assurance sera
également nécessaire
la couverture d'un risque consiste pour
l'essentiel à elle à évaluer la
probabilité qu'un événement se produise
ainsi que les dégâts financiers qu'ils
pourraient causer lorsque l'événement
est inédit et les dégâts
incommensurables
la taz évidemment se complique
de très nombreuses entreprises font
savoir que les pertes d'exploitation
qu'elles subissent actuellement ne sont
pas couvertes par leur contrat
d'assurance leurs dirigeants sont bien
sûr très inquiet monsieur le premier
ministre que peut faire le gouvernement
pour adapter le cadre assurantiel
à la gravité de la situation que nous
connaissons l'état d'urgence sanitaire
qui vient d'être créée at il vocation à
intégrer un volet assurantiel par
exemple sur le modèle du régime
existantes en matière de catastrophe
naturelle pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président manu rées il appartient au
chef du gouvernement de remercier le
parlement de lui avoir donné les moyens
en votant les deux lois que nous
soumettions à votre examen en lui
donnant les moyens de répondre et de
trouver des solutions aux difficultés
économiques considérables que suscite ce
confinement et l'interruption de
l'activité dans de très nombreux
secteurs
ces instruments nous les avons pas dans
ce cadre juridique que vous avez voté
nous l'avons utilisé et nous avons
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres vingt-cinq ordonnance je ne
fais pas de fétichisme du chiffre mais
25 ordonnance c'est un nombre
considérable qui permette secteur par
secteur et sujet par sujet d'essayer
d'apporter les solutions juridiques aux
questionnements et aux problèmes que
rencontre le tissu productif français et
pas seulement le tissu productif puisque
vous savez qu'un certain nombre de ces
ordonnances sont destinées à accompagner
les établissements de santé et la
situation des soigneurs 45 milliards je
les dis s'agissant du plan d'urgence 300
milliards de garanties accordées pour
permettre la poursuite du financement de
l'économie c'est indispensable
et ça montre l'engagement de l'état
c'est à dire de la nation vous évoquer
la situation des assureurs et il est
vrai vous l'avez indiqué monsieur le
président que en matière de garanties
s'agissant des pertes d'exploitation
les garanties en matière de perte
d'exploitation qui sont prévus dans un
certain nombre de contrats d'assurance
ne s'applique pas dans la grande
majorité des cas aux pertes
d'exploitation qui résulteraient d'autre
chose que d'un dommage matériel
autrement dit les contrats actuels
n'avaient pas pour l'immense majorité
d'entre eux
prévu ce type de dommages ce type
d'accident d'aller au contact en
septembre possibilité nous réfléchissons
plus exactement nous sommes intervenus
de trois façons la première c'est que
nous avons demandé au secteur des
assurances de participer de contribuer
au fonds de solidarité que nous avons
créée et nous allons faire en sorte que
dès le mois de mars et pour le mois
d'avril si c'est nécessaire les
assurances les assureurs puissent
contribuer à ce fonds de solidarité
ils se sont engagés à ce stade à sur un
montant d'environ 200 millions d'euros
pour le mois de mars
ça n'est pas négligeable et c'est
évidemment une façon d'apporter des
solutions aux indépendants aux toutes
petites entreprises qui se trouvent
confrontés à l'interruption de leur
activité le deuxième élément utile c'est
le fait de maintenir les garanties
d'assurance des tpe qui connaîtraient
des difficultés ou des retards de
paiement pendant toute la durée de la
période de suspension de l'activité
autrement dit dès lors qu'il n'ya pas de
recette et il ne peut pas y avoir de
perte de droits parce qu'il n'y aurait
plus de paiement des polices d'assurance
c'est important et c'est une
l'engagement qui a été pris par le
secteur
il sera garantie et puis même s'il est
probablement très tôt pour tirer tous
les enseignements de cette crise et
qu'il sera utile j'imagine d'y réfléchir
très rapidement le ministère de
l'économie et des finances va engager
des travaux avec les assureurs pour
imaginer les propositions innovantes qui
pourraient être les nôtres en matière de
mécanismes d'assurance permettant de
proposer des couvertures adapté à ce
type d'aléas et voyez bien monsieur le
c'est là dessus le président pardon que
en la matière il faut que nous puissions
avoir une discussion approfondie avec le
secteur des assurances afin de ne pas
afin de l'aider lui aussi à passer la
crise mais de veiller à ce qu'ils
puissent nous aider à passer cette crise
il ne faut pas le faire disparaître car
nous en avons besoin
mais il doit nous aider à passer cette
crise en nous aidant à ne pas
disparaître non plus c'est une
discussion à temps ce qui va se nouer
c'est une discussion absolument
nécessaire je ne peux pas ici maintenant
vous dire quels seront les résultats de
cette discussion mais je peux vous dire
notre disponibilité complète pour
l'engager et vous indiquer que le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
a déjà commencé merci la parole et tout
président philippe dallier quand le
groupe l'est républicain la parole
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
le sénat a voté à la quasi unanimité
sans votre contre les mesures d'urgence
pour soutenir l'activité et l'emploi
dans cette crise sanitaire qui va aussi
être une crise économique majeure
cependant il nous semble qu'il ya
quelques trous dans la raquette nous
l'avions dit en séance et les remonter
terrain semble le confirmer
concernant le chômage partiel est
monsieur le premier ministre il faudrait
puisque toutes les entreprises vont être
touchés par cette crise et étendre les
mesures aux tpe commerçants artisans qui
vont rester ouverts parce que leur
activité est considérée comme
essentielle mais qui vont quand même
subir une perte de chiffre d'affaires et
il faudrait les aider êtes vous prêt à
élargir cette mesure la mesure des 2500
euros pour ceux qui ont perdu 70% leur
chiffre d'affaires par rapport à mars
2019 sera de peu d'effet le report des
charges ou par exemple des factures de
gaz ou l'électricité à quelques mois ne
sera pas non plus suffisante la bonne
mesure c'est les 300 milliards de fonds
de garantie vous l'avais dit à la
condition de ce premier disque que les
banques soient en capacité effectivement
d'accorder ces prêts rapidement
largement partout sur le territoire
il semble qu'ils aient déjà les secteurs
ou certaines agences sont fermées il est
difficile de remettre des chèques ou de
remettre défend donc l assurance
pourriez vous nous donner un mot pour
ceux qui sont au travail et nous les
saluons tous il faut les encourager les
mesures qui ont été adoptées se limitent
pour ou salariés pour les grandes
entreprises probablement est-ce que vous
êtes trench premier ministre à faire à
prendre des dispositions effectivement
le secteur public pour les hôpitaux pour
tous ceux qui sont au travail et que
nous devons soutenir
enfin une question très particulière
beaucoup ont pu commander des masques en
chine les collectivités locales
notamment il semble qu'il y ait des
problèmes
effectivement d'acheminement des masques
commandés on parle de la mise en place
d'un pont aérien qu'est-ce qu'il en aime
chez premier ministre pour vous répondre
la parole et à monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur beaucoup de questions de votre
question d'abord je prends les points
positifs et je vous remercie de
souligner que la garantie d'emprunt
apportées par l'état à hauteur de 300
milliards est un élément favorable qui
doit évidemment être mises en oeuvre
désormais avec le soutien des banques
j'ai cru comprendre à la lecture d'un
certain nombre de messages dès ce matin
que les banques ayant constaté le vote
favorable du sénat que vous avez
mentionné ayant constaté la promulgation
de la loi avaient déjà commencé à
dresser à leurs clients les indications
leur disponibilité pour raccorder ces
emprunts je sais que certaines banques
ont été très réactives et notre objectif
c'est évidemment que cet instrument
servent les entreprises en ont besoin je
ne je ne méconnais pas les difficultés
qui çà et là peuvent se poser compte
tenu parfois plan de charge des agences
ou de la difficulté à faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des agences fonctionnent
bonnes conditions mais je peux vous
faire
et à monsieur le sénateur de la grande
mobilisation du secteur bancaire et de
la volonté de faire en sorte que cet
instrument puisse porté tous ses fruits
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
limites s'agissant des instruments
d'urgence que nous avons mis en place
peut-être pouvons-nous convenir
néanmoins monsieur le sénateur que le
dispositif d'activité partielle que nous
allons mettre en place est un dispositif
jamais constatée en france et nous avons
créé le paquet pardon pour cette
expression le paquet le plus généreux
d'europe dans le dispositif que nous
mettons en place les entreprises ne
subissent aucune perte
s'agissant de la décision de passer en
chômage partiel et les salariés voient
leur revenu garanti à une hauteur qui
est supérieur à ce qui se fait dans
d'autres pays y compris l'allemagne
monsieur le sénateur y compris
l'allemagne nous sommes donc allés très
loin dans le dispositif d'activité
partielle de façon là encore à permettre
aux entreprises et aux salariés bien
entendu de passer ce cap difficile
alors je comprends qu'on puisse se dire
qu'il en faudrait encore plus et
peut-être d'ailleurs en faudra-t-il plus
mais nous sommes dans les mesures
d'urgence qui permettent de passer le
cap sur la question du fonds de
solidarité pour les tpe n'oubliez pas
mais je sais que vous n'oublierez pas le
fait que ce fonds de solidarité est à
deux étages un étage automatique qui
veut que dès lors qu'on rentre dans un
certain nombre de conditions les 1500
euros sont versées automatiquement par
la dg fip et dans des conditions de
délais qui sont extrêmement restreint et
un deuxième étage qui lui pourra être
appréciée notamment grâce à
l'instruction des conseils régionaux
puisque nous avons travaillé avec les
régions pour faire en sorte qu'il puisse
nous aider à bien apprécier la situation
régionale et individuelle de chaque
entreprise donc pour le deuxième étage
du fonds de solidarité
il y aura une appréciation régionales et
il y aura aussi un accompagnement
autrement dit nous ne réduisons pas su
comme permettre le fonds de solidarité à
ce simple premier étage
il y aura deux étages qui doivent durer
aussi longtemps que la crise sanitaire
et donc les difficultés économiques vont
durer enfin vous poser d'autres
questions et je voudrais vous répondre
sur la question spécifique que vous avez
eu qu'à la fin de
s'agissant du pont aérien nous avons
effectivement un certain nombre de
commandes c'est vrai pour l'état c'est
vrai pour d'autres acteurs publics ou
privés il faut acheminer ces masques
dans de bonnes conditions nous sommes
entourés des conseils et de l'assistance
des meilleurs logisticiens nous avons
prévu des avions cargos qui ont en chine
cherchait les masques ils sont prévus
ils sont affrétés
on peut évoquer l'image du pont aérien
de fait c'est ce qui va se passer j'ai
même indiqué que dans la mesure où il
nous manquerait pour l'instant rien
n'indique qu'ils nous manquerait mais
dans la mesure où il nous manquerait des
avions pour aller chercher ces masques
nous serions en mesure non pas de
réquisitionner comme le dirait madame la
présidente s'agit mais de faire appel
aux capacités des compagnies nationales
qui aujourd'hui évidemment trouve a su
utiliser beaucoup moins et qui vous ont
indiqué leur disponibilité à qui nous
avons dit si nous avons besoin que ce
soit pour parfois faire revenir des
français de l'étranger qui sont bloqués
dans un pays là où les liaisons
commerciales sont interrompus ou pour
aller chercher ces masques nous ferions
appel à eux donc de ce point de vue les
choses sont claires
les commandes sont passées les avions
sont affrétés
il devrait servir dans des délais très
brefs croyez moi je suis le premier à
faire en sorte que ça puisse arriver
dans des délais très brefs puisque nous
avons besoin de cette ressource et je
pense que en la matière tout se passera
correctement mais permettez moi monsieur
le sénateur de ne faire preuve d'un
optimisme mesuré
je préfère retenir qu espérer en la
matière
le premier dans l'allier
we love green tva
le premier ministre il ya juste une
question à laquelle vous n'aviez pas
rond port du jeu vous demande simplement
d'y penser c'est effectivement pour ceux
qui sont en poste au travail dans des
conditions souvent difficiles dans tout
dans tous les secteurs effectivement que
l'on pense d'une manière ou d'une autre
à lézan à les encourager financièrement
il le mérite
je vois que le premier ministre
parfaitement entendu parole est à notre
collègue sabine van heghe pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain avait la
parole de sarko merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre la lutte
contre le coc vide 19 impose l'unité
nationale à laquelle nous souscrivons je
m'associe aux hommages que vous avez
formulé mes chers collègues à l'endroit
des citoyens qui travaillent dans des
conditions très difficiles au premier
rang desquels les personnels de santé
mais aussi les professionnels de tous
les secteurs qui permettent aux français
de disposer des biens et services
indispensables
je souligne également l'investissement
des fonctionnaires de nos services
publics dont on réalise plus son corps
en ces périodes de crise majeure qu'ils
sont non pas une dépense mais un
investissement
une protection dont on ne peut se passer
les moeurs et les élus locaux sont
également en première ligne l'unité
nationale ne doit pas empêcher le débat
démocratique et je veux me faire la
porte parole des interrogations
exprimées par nos concitoyens sur les
mesures sanitaires mises en place par le
gouvernement pour lutter contre cette
pandémie le renforcement du confinement
protège et sauve des vies
mais il est grand temps de mettre tout
en oeuvre pour se doter de masques de
tests de dépistage de gel
hydroalcoolique de respirateur qui
continue de manquer scandaleusement
quand les personnels mobilisés pour
combattre cette épidémie disposeront-ils
de ces éléments de protection et de
soins élémentaires
il faut tirer les leçons de cette crise
sanitaire sans précédent
et dès maintenant augmenter des moyens
financiers et humains qui manque
cruellement à notre système de santé oms
demande la généralisation des tests de
dépistage du pot vide 19 afin de
confiner les personnes positives et
ainsi éviter de nouvelles contaminations
les tests disponibles à ce jour et dans
les jours qui viennent seront absolument
insuffisant notamment quand les huit
cent mille résidents des ehpad sont
menacés d'une effroyable hécatombe
si des dispositions drastiques ne sont
pas prises de toute urgence
quand vous rangerez vous à ces
recommandations de l'om est ce monsieur
le ministre
et quand ces tests seront ils enfin
généralisée dans notre pays
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est à mme élise des solidarités
de la santé monsieur olivier ferrand
vous avez la parole
pour répondre à notre collègue jacques
bino avec merci de votre question madame
la sénatrice vague
elle me donne l'occasion de revenir sur
les annonces que j'ai fait à savoir que
nous allons continuer de nous conformer
scrupuleusement recommandations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé en
matière de tests les recommandations ont
évolué avec la connaissance du virus les
recommandations évolué avec l'apparition
de la pandémie et les recommandations
ont évolué avec l'identification des
différentes stratégies dans tous les
pays qui ont fait face en même temps que
nous quasiment en même temps que nous à
l'épidémie qui ont donc pu je dirais
mettre en place des stratégies qui leur
étaient propres en fonction des moyens
qu'ils avaient à disposition j'ai
annoncé que j'entendais l'appel du
directeur de l' oms qui disait tester
tester tester que cet enjeu était encore
plus important à l'heure où nous allions
des confiner la france à l'heure où les
français seront amenés à quitter leur
domicile pour retrouver une vie normale
l'enjeu de ces tests il est surtout là
pour savoir qui aura été malade et qu'il
n'aura pas été je peux vous confirmer
que nous avons sous quinzaine
la possibilité de passer des 5000 test
jours que nous réalisions à près de 20
25 mille tests jour en france dire une
multiplication pour mémoire l'allemagne
qui souvent c'est un exemple réalise
aujourd'hui douze mille tests par jour
donc sous quinzaine nous serons en
mesure de réaliser plus de 20 mille
tonnes par jour sans doute plus de 25
mille tonnes par jour cela sous-entend
aussi d'être capable d'amener
suffisamment de réactifs de kits de
prélèvement toutes ses commandes que
nous passons aux pays étrangers que nous
sommes en train de produire également
sur le territoire national
3 c'est un enjeu qui est important mais
on va pas se contenter des pcr parce que
la pcr c'est ce qui vous dit
être malade à un instant donné ce que
nous voulons c'est la sérologie et ça
aussi ça se développe à vitesse grand v
la recherche et l'innovation nous
permettront rapidement de savoir par une
prise de sang qui aura été immunisés
contre le virus asymptomatiques ou
symptomatique et qui n'aura pas été ça
ce sera très important pour savoir où
nous en sommes de l'épidémie à l'échelle
du pays à l'échelle de l'europe et à
l'échelle du monde et ce sera très
important au moment de déconfit n'est
pour que chacun puisse savoir s'ils
étaient immunisés pour de bon contre la
maladie
ou pas encore je pourrais vous citer
aussi les autotests les tests rapides
tous et tous ces tests qui sont en cours
de développement en cours de recherche
sur l'ensemble du territoire national et
en europe et ailleurs dans le monde
ils seront disponibles pour les français
dès qu'ils seront validées où que ce
soit dans le monde
voilà la réponse madame la sénatrice sur
la question des tests peut pas répondre
aux autres questions je n'ai pas assez
de temps je m'en excuse
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
laurent lafon pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
fermeture des écoles et établissements
scolaires a plongé l'ensemble du système
éducatif dans une situation inédite dans
ces conditions difficiles je tiens à
saluer évidemment l'implication des
directeurs d'établissement des
enseignants qui assurent la continuité
pédagogique il respect des programmes
dans notre pays
si globalement le constat est positif
quelques questions et interrogations
demeurent que je voudrais soulever
devant vous monsieur le ministre
en ce qui concerne égal accès à
l'enseignement chaque famille ne
possèdent pas toujours des équipements
réseaux et informatiques nécessaires
pour suivre un télé enseignement de
qualité de surcroît le rôle des parents
est essentiel et paddy de l'absence
contraintes des enseignants il existe de
grandes disparités entre les familles au
sein desquelles les parents sont
disponibles pour aider tout au long de
la journée leurs enfants et celle où les
parents sont nécessairement moins
présent le risque est grand de voir une
forme de décalage se renforcer entre
deux catégories de familles celle qui
dispose du temps nécessaire
la maîtrise dernier outil technologique
et les autres la question du rattrapage
une fois le confinement terminé se
posera pour certains enfants les
familles sont en demande d'information
de la part des enseignants sur le rôle
qu'elles doivent tenir dans
l'accompagnement pédagogique des enfants
il semblerait qu'il ait des disparités
de ce point de vue là d'un sonnet mans à
l'autre je voudrais attirer votre
attention pour finir sur deux points
particulier d'abord le ministère
d'éducation
engage actuellement les démarches
d'élaboration des ouvertures et des
fermetures de classes en vue de la
rentrée prochaine dans certaines
communes dans quelques jours des mers
pourrait recevoir des courriers leur
indiquant la fermeture des classes dans
leur école dans la période actuelle il
apparaît opportun de suspendre ce
calendrier est d'éviter des tensions
dont nous n'avons pas besoin
actuellement
par ailleurs je voudrais vous interroger
sur le la question du baccalauréat de
son calendrier et en particulier des
épreuves de contrôle continu qui devait
normalement débuter à l'issue des
vacances de printemps
est ce que ce calendrier est maintenu
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur la faune vous avez réussi en
deux minutes un concentré des questions
qui nécessitent environ une heure de
réponse je vais quand même aller droit
au but d'abord en rendant hommage comme
vous aux professeurs et l'ensemble des
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
un travail exceptionnel qui a été
accompli par tous et qui a permis dès le
début de la semaine dernière de d'entrer
dans ces circonstances exceptionnelles
avec véritablement du volontarisme et du
suivi de tous nos élèves
à telle enseigne d'ailleurs que parfois
les familles nous font remonter que
maintenant il ya parfois trop de travail
et nous allons réguler la situation de
façon à ce que nous puissions planifier
les prochaines semaines de manière
équilibrée pour l'ensemble des élèves de
france il ya un problème que vous avez
mentionné qui se posent dans ce genre de
cas c'est que en effet on peut accentuer
les inégalités puisque c'est des
circonstances familiales qui presque à
elle seule détermine la qualité de ce
qui se passe au quotidien pour les
enfants avec le travail qui se passe à
distance et donc nous devons compenser
ces inégalités familiale c'est pourquoi
j'ai demandé que chaque famille puisse
être contacté au moins une fois par
semaine et plus lorsqu'il s'agit de
familles défavorisées pour qu'il y ait
un suivi personnalisé un dialogue
professeurs parents au travers du
téléphone en particulier c'est un point
majeur
nous prenons une série de dispositions
pour avoir cette attention particulière
je pense à ce que nous faisons pour
l'enseignement professionnel par exemple
et puis nous prendrons des dispositions
aussi après la crise notamment des
modules de soutien scolaire gratuit
c'est un point essentiel s'agissant des
concours et examens avec
frédéric vidal nous avons publié un
communiqué hier coran dans un certain
nombre de détails pour le baccalauréat
je suis actuellement en discussion par
téléconférence avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales pour arriver à
une réponse qui pourrait d'ici une
dizaine de jours sur les modalités que
nous que nous retiendrons aussi bien
pour la date que pour la nature des
épreuves
mon but c'est évidemment de préserver
les intérêts de tous nos élèves
autrement dit qu'ils puissent avoir leur
diplôme pour ceux qui passent des
concours cette année qu'il puisse aussi
le passé et le faire selon des modalités
qui ne lèse personne et c'est pourquoi
c'est au cours des prochains jours et
des prochaines semaines que tout ceci se
précisera je vous remercie monsieur
lafon vous avez 11 secondes
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
éléments de réponse je voudrais juste
attirer votre attention sur la question
de la préparation de la rentrée scolaire
et des procédures mises en place
actuellement au sein des différents que
le rectorat et des tensions ou des
inquiétudes que ça peut générer qui ne
sont pas forcément indispensable dans la
période que nous traversons tous merci
mes chers collègues je vous demande
quelques secondes
j'informe le cedac une candidature pour
siéger au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques a été publié cette
candidature sera ratifiée si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure maintenant
prévues par notre règlement je voudrais
si vous le permettez saluer nos
collègues qui nous suivent actuellement
sur public sénat et qui m'envoient des
messages voudrais les remercier des
remontées questionnement informations
qu'il nous faut parvenir
depuis les territoires qu'ils
représentent et les français établis
hors de france
aussi qu'il représente avant de conclure
notre séance je vous rappelle mes chers
collègues que le droit de
questionnements continue naturellement à
s'exercer sous la forme de questions
écrites auxquelles j'avais le
gouvernement à apporter des réponses
dans les délais les plus raisonnables
c'est un utile rappel mais je crois que
c'est aussi l'exercice du droit de
contrôle vous remercie monsieur
le premier ministre madame et messieurs
les ministres je vais maintenant levé
notre séance la prochaine aura lieu le
mercredi 1er avril
je précise bien 1er avril pour une
séance exceptionnelle que question de
contrôler le gouvernement
notre séance est levée voilà pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement qui a permis aux sénateurs
d'interroger dans le calme le
gouvernement autour de la crise du
coronavirus vous l'avez constaté un
certain nombre de questions a été
consacrée notamment au volet économique
mais il ya aussi eu des questions sur
volet sanitaire notamment la question du
sénateur rené paul savary ou encore sur
l'outre-mer ou encore sur la situation
agricole 2 questions sur le sujet l'une
sur le secteur agricole et l'autre sur
les marchés l'occasion pour edouard
philippe de clarifier sa position sur la
fermeture des marchés écouté mon
objectif je vous le dis très simplement
c'est que dans les communes rurales où
le marché est indispensable et peut être
organisée dans de bonnes conditions
dans les quartiers des grandes villes où
le marché peut être organisée dans de
bonnes conditions ils puissent se tenir
pour une raison simple c'est que nos
agriculteurs ont besoin d'écouler leur
production et nos concitoyens ont besoin
de s'approvisionner en produits frais ça
n'est pas un luxe
ce n'est pas un accessoire c'est
indispensable
il faut simplement le faire dans des
conditions de civisme et de respect des
conditions sanitaires suffisantes et
encore une fois je le dis et j'ai
plaisir d'une certaine façon à le dire
au sénat
ce sont les maires qui sont les mieux
armés les mieux placés pour faire cette
proposition et les consignes que nous
passerons préfet seront évidemment des
consignes des couteaux et des consignes
de bon sens il leur appartiendra à
prendre les décisions
mais ils sauront ils sauront le faire
dans de bonnes conditions et peut-être
monsieur le préfet c'est vrai qu'entre
le moment de l' annonce et le moment de
la mise en oeuvre
il y a eu des questionnements posés ça
peut arriver
nous allons les régler le plus
rapidement possible
voilà donc pour cette mise au point d'
edouard philippe
le premier ministre qui a bien expliqué
que la fermeture des marchés reste la
règle mais en même temps il appelle à ce
que les marchés partout où ils sont
nécessaires a notamment dans l'écho
rumine les communes rurales puissent se
tenir dans de bonnes conditions et
notamment dans des conditions qui
puissent respecter et bien les distances
de sécurité mais aussi les règles
sanitaires
je vous le disais tout à l'heure il ya
aussi eu un certain nombre de questions
qui étaient consacrées et bien à la
situation du coronavirus en outre mer et
notamment à mayotte c'était l'objet de
votre question dany mohamed soly bonjour
je vous êtes aux sénateurs la république
en marche vice président du sénat
mayotte ce n'est pas un désert médical
nous avez vous dit en entretien c'est le
néant médicale quelle est actuellement
la situation dans votre département
votre département le plus pauvre de
france tout à fait la situation est très
préoccupante
notre premier cas a été enregistré le 14
mars et 10 jours après nous en sommes au
35e cas donc une progression fulgurante
avec seulement 16 lits d'hospitalisation
donc vraiment
une situation à surveiller et à prendre
en compte
très de façon très préoccupante quelles
mesures d'urgence à ce que vous réclamez
pour votre territoire aujourd'hui et est
ce que la réponse du ministre vous à du
premier ministre vous a suffi tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas vraiment eu
d'annoncé concernant votre territoire
dans une situation de crise comme
celle-ci où on ne peut pas vraiment
parler de ça de satisfaction moi ce que
j'ai retenu dans la réponse du premier
ministre c'est le fait le rappelle que
la solidarité nationale va jouer va
jouer pleinement
je fais partie de ceux qui demandent des
mesures exceptionnelles telles que
l'intervention de l'armée notamment un
bateau militaire
haug au large de l'île pour à la fois
tenir compte du caractère de gravité
exceptionnelle et être prêts à
intervenir
un temps en tant que de besoin votre
réaction au fait que l'on ait vu par
exemple qu'il ya eu des masques moisi et
inutilisable qui était délivré à la
réunion il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'inégalités entre la métropole et
l'outre-mer on le dit souvent mais c'est
encore une fois souligné par cette crise
avec des situations qui ne se sont pas
vraiment pas normal
oui les inégalités soient encore
davantage perceptible dans une crise
comme celle ci l'heure n'est pas à la
polémique nous savons que la gestion des
masques dans notre pays
on en tirera les conséquences après la
crise mais une fois que nous constatons
ces dysfonctionnements clients il faut
il faut agir et très rapidement fournir
également l'outre-mer en masques des
mesures barrières suffisante
eh bien merci beaucoup at any mohamed
soilihi d'avoir répondu à mes questions
et c'est le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer qui va
maintenant me rejoindre jean michel
blanquer requis a répondu à la dernière
question de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à l'instant
nous parlions accroissement des
inégalités qui sont mises en lumière
avec et bien cette crise du coronavirus
c'est aussi le cas à l'école que
pensez-vous notamment de ces enseignants
qui disent eh bien on ne peut pas
avancer dans le programme dans ces
conditions on a des élèves qui ont un
niveau trop hétérogène notamment dans
les quartiers parce que vous les
comprenez est ce que vous comprenez
cette démarche en que vous avait plutôt
voulu qu'on avance dans programme
jusqu'ici ont d'abord je veux saluer le
travail que les professeurs ont fait
depuis une dizaine de jours depuis ce
moment nous sommes entrés dans la
période de confinement c'était un grand
défi à l'échelle nationale défi
d'ailleurs convenu de très grands un
grand nombre de pays dans le monde
et lorsqu'on voit ce que la france a
fait ça commence déjà à être saluée
parce que on a réussi à couvrir tout le
territoire et à coup et a touché
pratiquement tous les élèves nous
continuons d'ailleurs à travailler
d'élèves salue aujourd'hui beaucoup les
efforts de leurs enseignants
effectivement et donc toute la france
voit ce travail des professeurs qui a un
travail remarquable cet investissement
cet engagement qui est en plus un
engagement personnalisés alors par
ailleurs c'est tout à fait justes
malheureusement de dire que
une telle période peut accentuer les
inégalités puisque chaque élève dépend
de son contexte familial donc c'est à
nous éducation nationale de nous
efforcer de compenser ces inégalités
c'est pourquoi il va y avoir des efforts
spécifiques vis-à-vis des élèves les
plus en difficulté pendant la période de
crise et puis après la période de crise
donc pendant la période de crise ça
signifie que j'ai demandé que les
familles soient contactés au moins une
fois par semaine si possible plus pour
les élèves les plus en difficulté avec
des cibles particulières par exemple les
élèves en réseau d'éducation prioritaire
les élèves en milieu rural éloigner les
élèves de lycées professionnels qui ont
besoin qu'on ait une attention
particulière pour eux évidemment sa
rencontre certaines difficultés mais ces
difficultés ne doivent pas nous nous
arrêter la pire des conclusions c'est
vrai dire on fait rien on doit au
contraire être très volontariste on
prendra des mesures aussi après la crise
notamment des modules de soutien
scolaire gratuit qui seront vraiment
proposé en grand nombre pour les élèves
qui auraient des retards à rattraper
y compris par exemple à la fin du mois
d'août quand il faut un peu avant la
rentrée scolaire
ba se préparait à réussir dans la classe
supérieure dans laquelle on est rentré
autre difficulté c'est la fracture
numérique
il ya bien sûr bien des élèves qui n'ont
pas d'ordinateur et surtout il y en a
qui n'ont pas de connexion internet pour
eux et bien c'est vraiment extrêmement
compliquée qu est ce que vous leur
proposez alors c'est aussi un autre
problème se d'inégalités puisque rond
concert qui environ 5% des ménages qui
n'ont pas d'ordinateur
j'ai aussi en tête la réalité que
traverse beaucoup de familles en ce
moment qui est que parfois on a un
ordinateur mais si on est quatre membres
de la famille à voir le télétravail plus
l'éducation à distance
ça pose des problèmes que évidemment
nous nous regardons le but déjà cette
équipe et ceux qui n'ont rien
nous le faisons aujourd'hui en lien avec
les collectivités locales puisque c'est
souvent elle qui fournissent le matériel
informatique aux écoles au collège et au
lycée donc nous sommes entendus pour que
du matériel puisse être prêté aux
familles pendant cette période et c'est
ce qui s'est passé pour beaucoup dans
beaucoup de cas nous n'avons pas encore
couverts 100 % des cas donc nous faisons
un travail là en ce moment avec les
rectorats pour recenser les problèmes
trouver des solutions travailler avec le
monde associatif par exemple vous avez
emmaüs connect qui est une très belle
association qui avec qui on est en
relation pour pré permettre qu'il n'y
ait pas cette fracture numérique pour
les familles les plus démunies est donc
cet ensemble de mesures doivent faire
que nous réussissons à vaincre la
fracture numérique et même affaire que
cette crise soit une occasion bien de
progresser sur ce que sur cette question
il ya jean michel blanc car le conseil
scientifique a dit qu'il fallait prévoir
un confinement d'au moins six semaines
en disant que c'était avec beaucoup
d'incertitudes qu'il disait cela est ce
que vous vous maintenez encore votre
prévisions la reprise des cours pour le
4 mai parce que ce que j'avais dit sur
ce sujet est évidemment totalement
dépendant des décisions en plus général
qui sont prises par le président et le
premier ministre sur la deux la durée de
confinement donc je n'ai je n'ai jamais
dit que c'était certainement le 4 mai
j'ai dit que c'était l'hypothèse de
travail que nous avions mais que nous
avions aussi d'autres scénarios en
fonction du confinement général dans
lequel la france sera ce que vient dire
le conseil scientifique n'est pas
contradictoire avec ce scénario nous
sanusi amènerait au contraire donc c'est
ce que nous verrons donc encore une fois
je travaille beaucoup sur l'hypothèse de
retour après les vacances de printemps
mais on ne peut pas en être certain
c'est une hypothèse
ça va dépendre évidemment du pic de
l'épidémie de ce que nous diront
les experts sanitaires et médicaux et
donc pour l'instant dans l'état vous
maintenez le bac au 17 juin
le baccalauréat va forcément connaître
certaines évolutions soient de date soit
de contenu soient un peu des deux pour
tenir compte de ce qui est en train de
se passer
j'écoute beaucoup en ce moment les
différentes organisations
représentatives jeu en téléconférence
toute la journée avec les différents
interlocuteurs du ministère de
l'éducation nationale c'est ce qui va me
permettre au cours des prochains jours
et je pense dans le courant de la
semaine prochaine de pouvoir affiner ce
que nous pouvons dire sur le
baccalauréat en tout cas mon premier
critère c'est de garantir aux élèves
qu'ils pourront avoir un baccalauréat
cette année et ont pressé le tout avec
bienveillance évidemment puisque il
s'agit des personnes sans tenir compte
du réel montrer que notre nation est
unie et que notre éducation nationale
est active
tout simplement pour garantir les droits
de chacun et surtout faire en sorte que
le niveau général soit bon dans notre
pays
une dernière question très concrète que
se posent beaucoup de parents
actuellement est ce que vous maintenez
bien les congés de printemps et où est
ce qu'il y aura encore écoles peut-être
pour rattraper le retard qu'ils aient
pris comment ça va se passer
non d'abord parfois des fausses
nouvelles ou des mauvaises
interprétations sur les vacances d'été
je tiens à rappeler qu'elle ne bouge pas
s'agissant des vacances de printemps
elles vont forcément être un des
facteurs un peu studieuse puisque tout
le monde sera chez soi donc on peut
toujours discuter de finalement du
moment où elles se passe mais surtout ce
que j'enverrai des messages ces
prochains temps sur des recommandations
que nous faisons sur l'activité des
élèves c'est pas la même chose
d'ailleurs selon l'âge qu'ils ont par
exemple le sujet de la lecture de livres
doit être considérablement courage et on
va faire des opérations pour promouvoir
le livre et la lecture de livres et
toutes sortes d'activités qui touche pas
forcément directement les programmes
scolaires mais plutôt la culture
générale de nos élèves nous devons faire
en sorte que cette période difficile
pour tout le monde soit quand même une
période riche pour nos enfants et nos
adolescents et que ce soit pas du temps
perdu mais du temps du temps gagné
notamment pour la culture de nos enfants
mais vous demanderez pas aux enseignants
par d'onde de continuer à envoyer
des programmes scolaires sur ces deux
semaines de printemps non il faut qu'il
y ait une pause à un moment donné donc
on est une pause dans ce qu'on demande
en revanche que les élèves
prenez les élèves de première et
terminale par exemple même quand il n'y
a pas une crise de ce type pour les
vacances de printemps sont studieuses
pour eux pour qu'ils préparent le
baccalauréat
donc il peut y avoir du travail donné
comme ça arrive pendant les vacances
savait pas dire qu'on est tous les jours
devant son écran en lien avec son
professeur pendant la période qui était
normalement celle des vacances eh bien
merci beaucoup jean michel blanquer
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et je
vais donc accueillir le ministre des
relations avec le parlement
marc fesneau marc fesneau donc mise des
relations avec le parlement merci
beaucoup de venir nous rejoindre dans ce
dispositif après donc cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
est ce que c'est important de maintenir
pour vous et bien ce rendez-vous avec le
parlement en l'état dans cette période
bien sûr de crise du coronavirus on dit
que faudrait peut-être mieux maintenir
cela mais peut-être par vidéoconférence
dans l'est dans les prochains jours il
me semble que c'est important de le
maintenir
il ya une forme d'ailleurs qui est qui a
été souhaité par le sénat le président
du sénat qui ne forment qu il respecte
les règles de confinement et compris
derrière les règles de confinement pour
donner les télés radios distance qu'il
faut avoir entre nous y compris pour
donner les interviews je pense que c'est
un moment comme une volonté que nous
partageons entre le gouvernement et le
parlement qui est celle de pouvoir
dialoguer de pouvoir informer de pouvoir
faire remonter un certain nombre de
difficultés et aussi de pouvoir rendre
des comptes au fond devant le parlement
devant l'exigence qui essaient de normal
de l'évaluation et du contrôle et donc
je trouve que cette séance comme les
précédentes a permis aussi d'éclairer un
certain nombre de décisions parfois de
préciser un certain nombre de décisions
et je pense que c'est un moment utile
pas seulement ce n'est pas une affaire
entre parlementaires et ministre c'est
une affaire qui est concret pour les
français est ce que ce n'est pas
d'autant plus important que et bien à le
parlement certains parlementaires jugent
qu'il va y avoir insuffisamment du
contrôle sur cette période de
coronavirus sachant que eh bien il ya
une dérogation pour la prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
il ya seulement il ya deux mois avant
qu'il puisse y avoir une nouvelle loi
par le parlement
il ya deux mois pour proroger au projet
c'est loin avec ce qui a été adopté
je le rappelle quasi unanimement par le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale donc tout
le monde avait conscience de ce que nous
faisions
je souhaite d'ailleurs que nous n'ayons
pas la pro a prorogé cet état d'urgence
sanitaire
sauf que nous verrons au gré des mesures
que nous avons pu prendre de la façon
dont les s'applique sur le territoire
français si nous auront lieu ou pas de
projets cet état d'urgence sanitaire
mais je crois que le débat j'ai assisté
aux débats samedi et dimanche à
l'assemblée ou au sénat
et je pense que nous partageons la
volonté que l'action du gouvernement
plus ses traits value et est contrôlée
ont continué je pense que c'est avant de
se poser des problèmes de dans deux mois
je pense que c'est bien que nous
essayons d'évaluer et de contrôler et de
travailler ensemble au service des
français me semble-t-il dans cette crise
aujourd'hui justement c'était un
problème ici et maintenant
le ministère de l'agriculture a appelé
les français qui n'ont rien à faire à se
rendre dans les champs est-ce que vous
admettez que sur la forme c'était un
petit peu contradictoire avec le
confinement est ce que vous pouvez bien
expliciter la volonté du gouvernement
sur ce sujet et quels sont les problèmes
auxquels l'agriculture doit faire face
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas entendu d'abord
dans les mots du ministre de
l'agriculture des français qui n'ont
rien à rien à faire c'est ce qui vous
lance porté volontaire d'une certaine
façon comme beaucoup de français le font
ici pour rendre un service pour amener
des courses à son voisin ou à sa voisine
qui est âgée ici pour aider dans tel ou
tel geste le plus simple je veux dire il
ya beaucoup de français aujourd'hui il y
compris ceux qui nous écoutent là qu'ils
rendent des tas de services et non pas
parce qu'ils n'ont rien à faire mais
parce qu'ils ont envie de se mettre au
service de la collectivité et c'est ce
qu'ont rappelé est de mise
l'écriture la ministre du travail mise
de l'économie et des finances on rentre
dans la phase de production active d'un
certain nombre de productions et au
moment où il ya besoin de nourrir les
français il n'y a pas de problème de
pénurie mais il faut en tout cas que
nous soyons vigilants dans le temps si
ce devait s'inscrire dans le temps cette
question de l'état d'urgence sanitaire à
ce que l'ensemble des marques des
marchés on pourra en parler tout à
l'heure où l'ensemble des commerces qui
traite de ces questions puissent être
alimentés donc ça a été dit dans le
cadre très simple avec des règles qui
vont être affinée et préciser avec les
employeurs parce qu'il n'est pas
question de déranger les questions de
sécurité et ce qui est valable pour les
saisonniers habituels va signifier du
transport ce qui est belle mais l'est-il
oui mais c'est bien ce qu'on a essayé de
dire depuis le début ce que
il y avait des activités qui était
essentielle et que beaucoup de français
y compris ceux qui nous écoutent qui
travaillent aujourd'hui le fond au
service qu'on pourrait appeler une
certaine façon une économie de guerre il
ya besoin de gens qui s'occupent de
récolter a besoin des gens qui
s'occupent d'impact et il ya besoin de
gens qui s'occupent de transporter des
besoins des gens qui s'occupent de
mettre en rayon il ya des gens des gens
qui vendent dans les commerces
ça c'est une chaîne qui est très
précieuse et donc il ya beaucoup de
métiers qui sont nécessaires pour
simplement maintenir des activités
essentielles au fond qu'est celle de
pouvoir se nourrir se chauffer avoir de
l'électricité avoir du réseau voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça eh bien merci
beaucoup à marseille nous d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et je vais
maintenant accueillir le sénateur
socialiste du val d'oise rachid tu es
mal rachid tu es mal vous avez tout à
l'heure interroger le gouvernement a
notamment sur le volet économique de
l'encadrement des prix est ce que vous
avez obtenu satisfaction
non je crois que d'ailleurs que la
ministre à quelques problèmes en
économie aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il y
à déjà des tensions sur un centre de
prix nous savons tienne difficultés pour
la couture de fournir avec au milieu de
ça les transporteurs etc etc
nous savons qu'il ya des tensions et ce
qui t'a c'est invraisemblable c'est la
non modestie mais ça c'est triste mais
ce qui était assez invraisemblable c'est
que nous avons votée il ya trois jours
quatre jours maintenant ici au sénat
le lap au site et de bloquer les prix et
la ministre refuse encore une fois
d'utiliser un outil que nous avons tous
voté en extrême urgence
je ne comprends pas et je crois que les
français ne comprennent pas parce que il
ne faut pas ajouter de la crise sociale
la crise du pouvoir d'achat
à la crise sanitaire qui existe dans
notre pays justement quel regard portez
vous sur les 25 ordonnance qu'il ya eu
ce matin il y en a pour vraiment
protéger les salariés mais il y en a
aussi pour par exemple et bien faire
sauter le verrou de la durée du travail
enfin passer à 60 heures dans les
entreprises jugées essentielles ou
encore des mesures sur les congés à
l'initiative des
des non pas des salariés mais bien des
employeurs est-ce que vous jugez que
cela met à mal le droit du travail
aujourd'hui
oui d'ailleurs je rappelle que
d'ailleurs il ya une mesure qui n'est
pas par contre annoncé que nous avons
nous réclamer mais sans succès au
gouvernement c'est surtout des moyens
financiers nouveaux pour l'hôpital parce
que nous avons aussi voter des mesures
budgétaires n'y avait pas de nom
contrairement au discours du
gouvernement il n'y avait pas cela fut
le cas tout à fait et donc certains
c'est un vrai problème parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya besoin de
personnels et puis aussi je le dis de
masques etc
parce que quand on voit ce qui se passe
dans les hôpitaux mais sur les
ordonnances que vous évoquez sein des
sujets pour lequel mon groupe socialiste
s'est abstenu en disant à la fois et
avait besoin de mesures d'urgence
sanitaire ce qui était fait mais en même
temps on ne pouvait pas accepter der des
der très aussi significatif sur le droit
social mais également sur les libertés
individuelles ainsi que sur les droits
du parlement à pouvoir faire la loi ou
contrôler le gouvernement
donc oui aujourd'hui à des reculs
impressionnant sur lequel nous sommes
bien sûr opposés et nous espérons très
rapidement mettre fin à cette crise et
revenir sur ces propositions passé à
combustion ces mesures du gouvernement
qui je crois qu'à ce modèle social or
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien ce qui fait
que nous essayons d'avancer pour juguler
la crise et parce que le modèle social
parce que le service public parce que
les femmes et les hommes de bonne
volonté sont là et je pense qu'il faut
plutôt les récompenses et les remercier
plutôt que de retaper sur la tête avec
des mesures inacceptables justement ce
matin martin hirsch a lancé un appel un
appel très alarmant il appelle à la
réquisition des soignants face et bien
au pic de l'épidémie convoi arrivait en
ile de france
et puis aussi à leur reconnaissance sous
forme de prime vous appelez à ce qu'il
soit entendu
bien sûr sur les primes je viens de le
dire nous avons souhaité nous
socialistes dans l'hémicycle qu'il y ait
de l'argent pour l'hopital et l'hôpital
quand je dis l'hôpital je viens dément
je pense aussi aux ehpad à toute la
structure sanitaire et sociale de notre
pays aussi qui a aujourd'hui à protéger
et à sauvegarder et donc à aider les
salariés
et puis sur l'autre partie nous
demandons à ce que effectivement avec le
milieu
privé on puisse élargir au maximum et et
moi je je salue notamment
je peux vous le dire bernard jomier qui
est sénateur de mon groupe qui est
médecin de profession qui a rejoint là
et qui sera lui aussi va prendre ses
tours de garde comme d'autres mais je le
dis il faut il faut c'est tout à fait il
faut aussi que les il faut le saluer
pour cela mais ici il faut et puis
toutes celles et tous ceux qui comme lui
le fond je ne sais pas parce que il a
lancé mais il faut aussi donner des
moyens aujourd'hui il faut des masques
et je crois que dans l'hôpital il manque
aussi des masques les outils de
protection et je crois que c'est
important de le rappeler
eh bien merci beaucoup un rachid tu es
mal d'avoir répondu à mes questions et
puis je vous propose à présent et bien
d'écouter l'interview d'anne espagne et
or une hache et la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie que
j'ai pu interviewer il y à quelques
minutes écoutez je leur réponds que nous
sommes dans une situation inédite une
situation où une partie des français ne
peuvent pas aller travailler
ils ne peuvent pas aller travailler
parce qu'ils doivent garder leurs
enfants ils ne peuvent pas aller
travailler parce que ils ont un terrain
médical qui fait que nous devons les
mettre à l'abri et donc il est hors de
question qu'il reste dans cette
situation de travail pour les autres qui
sont en bonne santé la question est
comment continue-t-on à nourrir 20 67
millions de français comment fait-on
pour transformer des lignes
industrielles complètes pour produire du
jeu l'hydraulique ce que nous sommes en
train de faire pour produire des masques
en tissu ce que nous sommes en train de
faire et pour produire plus de 1000
dicaments au service de notre première
ligne sanitaire est donc dans ce cas là
eh bien il faut bouger les murs il faut
faire en sorte que notre pays fonctionne
il faut prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent
et je peux vous dire que les médecins
qui sont à l'hôpital que les infirmières
et que les aides soignantes
ça fait bien longtemps qu'elles sont
dans ce rythme de travail et elles le
font avec énormément pour vous
énormément d'autres responsabilités je
crois qu'on doit être à la hauteur de ce
qu'ils font votre collègue didier
guillaume justement puisque vous parlez
de cela qu'ils appellent les français
qui n'ont rien à faire à se rendre dans
les champs à ce que vous admettez que
sur la forme cela n'ait pas été très
bien compris cela a été jugé
contradictoire avec le confinement cela
et est clarifié depuis mai sur cette
prise de parole l'enjeu il est très
clair
protéger au maximum les français mais il
faut pouvoir aussi continuer à faire
tourner le pays est aujourd'hui nous
avons un sujet l'agriculture est là un
rythme
c'est le moment d'aller moissonner c'est
le moment de faire des semis c'est le
moment de préparer on la façon dont on
va récolter dans quelques mois et donc
c'est un appel bien sûr organisé bien
sûr qu'on ne fait pas n'importe quoi et
qui à chaque fois à chaque fois qu'on
demande aux français d'aller travailler
la première chose que nous exigeons des
entreprises c'est qu'elle clarifie les
modalités sanitaire de reprise du
travail et que tous les gestes barrières
et toutes les conditions de travail
soient adaptés à cette situation
particulière un mot rapidement pour
conclure sur les efforts imprévus et
bien par ses ordonnances pour les
entreprises notamment 1500 euros pour le
mois de mars prévu pour les tpe un
deuxième étage à 2000 euros a dit tout à
l'heure bruno le maire c'est suffisant
certaines entreprises ont perdu 70 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires au mois de mars
vont pouvoir aussi bénéficier de
l'ensemble des autres dispositifs je les
rappelle le report des échéances
sociales et fiscales le fait d'avoir des
garanties sur les prêts et de pouvoir en
tirer de nouveaux notamment des lignes
de trésorerie
le fait également de bénéficier du
chômage partiel ce qui leur permet
d'annuler certaines charges le fait de
pouvoir pour les plus petits d'entre
elles reporter leurs factures d'énergie
et d'eau
tous ces éléments là au delà des 1500
euro contribueront à les rendre plus
confortable
voilà pour cette interview de la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie agnès pannier-runacher
enregistré il ya quelques instants c'est
la fin de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement si on
spécial bien sûr entièrement consacré
aux coronavirus je remercie toutes les
équipes qui ont permis et bien cette
émission possibles notamment les équipes
techniques qu'il s'agisse de notamment
des sonneries claveau de philippe de
sony au niveau éditorial
amélie gauthier ou encore halle berry
papon ripamonti ou encore aussi et
n'diaye qui en télétravail est une
merveilleuse script prochaine séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
question deux contrôles et bien le 1er
avril
très bonne journée à tous sur public
sénat
[Musique]